bonjour merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors cette annonce de
l'arabie saoudite d'ouvrir son espace
aérien on voit la destination et en
provenance des émirats arabes unis est
une étape de plus dans la normalisation
des relations entre israël et une partie
du monde arabe
oui en tout cas cela conforte l'idée
selon laquelle il y a une forme de
détente de la part des pays du monde
arabe comme voulu citer mais plus
précisément des pays du golfe
on sait que les émirats arabes unis sont
maintenant le troisième pays à avoir
normalisé leurs relations diplomatiques
avec israël après l'egypte en 1979 et la
jordanie en 1994 et l'autorisation du
survol de vue territoire saoudien qui
précisément ne mentionne pas israël mais
évidemment cela va permettre aux
passagers donc à destination de l'asie
donc de gagner évidemment une bonne
partie du temps qu'il mettait dont une
lui égard au contournement obligé par
l'arabie saoudite ne ce n'est que le
prémice d'une tentative diplomatique
d'ouvrir d'autres relations
diplomatiques on évoque le fait que
bahreïn le soudan on a même évoqué le
maroc qui pourrait ou qui serait en tout
cas
sollicitée de la part du prince héritier
puisque le roi salman est encore
hospitalisé le prince héritier -
benslimane qui évidemment est dans la
convergence diplomatiques avec le gendre
du président américain jared kushner qui
voit là d'une certaine façon une partie
de son plan du siècle légitimer alors il
s'agit aussi d'un rapprochement de
circonstance puisque les trois pays
israël est les émirats et l'arabie
saoudite ont un ennemi en en commun
c'est l'iran comment est ce que peut
justement et bien réagir téhéran à ce
rapprochement émirates israël aux
saoudiens disons que les trois pays ont
deux ennemis en commun outre l'iran le
qatar vous avez mentionné qu'il ya deux
pays qui pour l'instant n'ont pas de
possibilité de vols puisque les
relations diplomatiques ne sont pas
reconnus avec l'iran depuis 1979 et ont
été abrogés à partir du 2 juin 2017
souvenons nous le position qui alliez
quatre pays contre le qatar donc je
crois que cette situation évidemment
conforte de nouveau l'idée selon
laquelle un certain nombre de pays
arabes jouent une carte diplomatique de
rapprochement avec israël
avec là aussi peut-être un troisième une
troisième victime
outre l'iran et le qatar qui est la
cause palestinienne puisqu'une bonne
partie des pays qui normalise ou qui
aurait vocation à normaliser leurs
relations diplomatiques avec l'arabie
saoudite sont en train d'une certaine
manière d'oublier les engagements qui
ont été les leurs qui sont encore
officiellement les leurres l'arabie
saoudite a dit que la position de la
diplomatie saoudienne le changeait pas
les avis de la cause palestinienne mais
bien évidemment les palestiniens sont
particulièrement irrité du fait que ce
survol l'ouverture d'un survol du
territoire saoudien par la compagnie el
al et donc potentiellement d'autres
compagnies air india par exemple a aussi
autorisé était autorisé à survoler le
territoire saoudien et l'ouverture de
récents des pratiques avec les émirats
arabes unis conforte l'idée qu'il y à
une sorte de césure qui s'est comporté
pendant sept durant ces deux derniers
mois qui voit un certain nombre de pays
traditionnellement soutien de la cause
palestinienne se rapprocher
singulièrement diplomatique d'israël
alors justement vous parliez de la cause
palestinienne et on peut aussi évoquer
la situation au yémen au liban où les
tensions entre l'iran et l'arabie
saoudite se retrouvaient ce qu'on peut
craindre davantage de de dommages de
dégâts collatéraux à ce que la situation
peut empirer dans la région allait déjà
particulièrement perturbé et je ne crois
pas que ce c'est juste à cause d'une
ouverture diplomatique que cela va
agréger toutes une série de dedic mans
qui avait précédé cette décision c'est
une décision diplomatique mais c'est
aussi une décision économique et d'une
certaine manière c'est une position
économique qui satisfait les deux
parties israël et l'arabie saoudite
l'arabie saoudite qui avait
avec le prince héritier mohammed bin
salman fortement investi dans le secteur
du tourisme qui évidemment a tout à fait
pâti de l'opprobre international lié à
l'assassinât de jamal khashoggi il ya de
cela un an et demi et c'est évidemment
d'attirer de nouveau des touristes sur
son territoire d'ailleurs l'arabie
saoudite qui avait autorisé pour la
première fois l'année dernière
l'ouverture de visa à but touristique
n'a pas vu beaucoup de touristes
allaient pourtant dans les lieux qu'elle
avait essayé de mettre en avant je pense
notamment au mausolée nabatéens de el
oula donc il ya évidemment une dimension
politique une dimension économique
mais il ya effectivement aussi des
implications régionales les implications
régionales consiste à conforter l'idée
selon laquelle l'agenda de ryad et
l'agenda d'abou dhabi est de plus en
plus convergents dans un certain nombre
de théâtres d'opération vous avez
mentionné le yémen on pourrait
mentionner la syrie il faudrait aussi
rajouter la libye puisque les deux pays
sont engagés
là aussi dans une sorte de confrontation
frontale entre d'un côté ceux qui
soutiennent le maréchalat star est
précisément l'egypte les émirats arabes
unis l'arabie saoudite et singulièrement
la russie et de l'autre les deux ennemis
là aussi sur ce territoire comme dans
d'autres territoires
j'ai déjà mon seigneur le qatar mais il
faut aussi avoir l'esprit que l'arabie
saoudite et israël ont aussi un autre
ennemi en commun ou en tout cas voit
d'un très mauvais oeil l'activisme
militaires diplomatiques et économiques
de la turquie en méditerranée orientale
est évidemment en syrie et dans le
proche orient
emmanuel dupuis bercy pour cet éclairage
je rappelle que vous êtes président de
nip ce l institut prospective et
sécurité en europe à un think tank
spécialisé sur les questions de défense
et de sécurité
merci beaucoup